well i'll say that i disagree
i disagree so i disagree with that
unfortunately i disagree
that's not my wallet they are bad i
disagree i disagree i disagree
i disagree i disagree i disagree
i think it's a borderline ridiculous
statement
i'm jordan schlansky and apparently i
have opinions
i think everyone does i've asked you for
your opinion so i can determine whether
i agree
or disagree this is what i'm here to do
uh so let's proceed the first opinion
i've received
is from uh h lebo raw
1933. i don't know the significance of
1933
he looks from his avatar too young to
have been born that year
although i can tell you that 1933 is one
year
after the introduction of george
washington's face
on the united states quarter this person
writes in my opinion bologna is the best
place to visit in italy
i disagree i think bologna is amazing
some of the greatest food in italy comes
out of bologna things like
um mortadella and shishito
is from nearby in the same region and
parmigiano
is also from nearby however my
preference is the countryside of italy i
would disqualify
any city in italy from being the best
place to visit because i like being out
in nature i like wide open spaces i like
calm and serenity one of the things we
don't have
living in the big cities like new york
and los angeles two cities which i've
lived
is peace and quiet and uh that is why i
value the countryside of italy
particularly the landlocked countrysides
of tuscany
amelia romania which is the region that
bologna is in also
umbria uh moving on the prequels for
star wars
aren't that bad uh unfortunately i
disagree
that's not my wallet they are bad to me
they're not
even star wars i've spoken about this
before but they have
uh star wars characters uh apparently
everyone has to be related to somebody
for star wars to feel justified in
presenting a storyline
nevertheless they have star wars
characters but it's not
done in the style of the original star
wars films
they don't feel like star wars films
short of john williams score
which in some sense does connect
all those films i feel like the initial
three films have a look and feel
all their own bobby lessig says i
believe
you look better with the beer bobby's
referring to me
i agree i believe i look better with a
beard too i think
a lot of men look better with beards and
it has to do with the fact
that evolutionarily speaking the beard
is a
what's called a secondary sexual
characteristic evolution provided the
beard for a number of reasons
um many people are aware of the fact
that it keeps the face warm
but there's more there's more to it than
that there's the fact that it
gives the appearance of a larger jaw
which for a male
asserts an image of dominance dominance
for a male was usually the key to
survival
when i have a beard i may appear
stronger i may appear more dominant
and i may appear more sexually
attractive however
in my case i've decided to not have a
beard because i value comfort
more than my own sexual attractiveness
i'm not particularly concerned with
being sexually attractive
i like the comfort of having my bare
skin exposed to the elements i like the
feeling of the sun on my face
i like the feeling of a nice cooling
breeze having a beard interferes with my
connection
with the environment around me the less
that's between me
and the elements the better so for that
reason
uh i while agreeing with bobby
choose not to have a beer chester shucks
says
starbucks does decent coffee
i disagree i tried it and
i don't like it this opinion is from dan
ban 444
who says regis is better than trebek
i disagree i wouldn't say i'm
particularly a fan of either regis
philbin or alex trebek but i do like the
pensiveness of alex trebek where i feel
like regis
relies more on his abundant energy
one thing that used to bother me about
alex trebek back in the 80s was his
physical presentation i wasn't a fan of
him having a mustache and
and more importantly i was never a fan
of the double-breasted suit now the
double-breasted suit you don't see it so
much anymore
but um it has a story history but
in the 80s you saw double-breasted suits
on
two prominent television personalities
there was alex trebek and then there was
david letterman david letterman
committed the additional crime of
wearing a double-breasted suit
unbuttoned
which should never be done even
throughout history that was something
that should never have been done the
double-breasted suit
in contrast to clothing that's tailored
to slim
the male physique the double-breasted
suit served to widen it i don't
understand what the logic was behind
um wearing it in a modern day scenario
um nevertheless alex trebek uh
presented a mustache with no beard
and a double-breasted suit concurrently
and to me
that was uh an ascetic displeasure so
uh once he switched to single-breasted
suits and shaved his mustache i was able
to enjoy his pens of nature
without the distraction of his
objectionable appearance pulpud pulpud1
who says that men and women
which is grammatically incorrect because
there's no consistency here
if we're talking about men then we would
be talking about women
or we could talk about one man and one
woman
um this mixes the two in an ineffective
way
nevertheless i understand the idea is
effectively communicated
i'll change it for your benefit men and
women cannot have platonic
relationship relationships
or a platonic relationship either i
disagree
i think it's a borderline ridiculous
statement
i entertain all opinions i'm not here to
to judge
the integrity of the opinions but uh
well of course the men and women can
have platonic relationships i would hope
that
a man would have a platonic relationship
with his mother for example
um and i think the rest is self-evident
some things are better left unsaid other
than i disagree
but one this opinion is from lizzy802
bacon is overrated i agree i never
understood the big deal about bacon this
opinion is uh
from renee walk who says we are living
in a simulation
uh i disagree
but it's a fascinating theory
if we were in a simulation it wouldn't
be our place to know and in fact
it's a safe position to
disagree with this because if we are in
fact in a simulation
the success of that stimulation depends
on our belief in the simulation itself
so if life were a simulation and i
believed in it
i am furthering the cause of life
life is i know it um and life as
everyone around me knows it the other
interesting
um theory to entertain is that life may
be a simulation where
you are the only person that is not
aware of it that everyone around you is
an actor and in on the secret whereas
you are not
another fascinating situation um but one
again that i ultimately
don't believe in so in the end i
disagree with
renee